present Trump is trying to get rid of
the NAFTA agreement with Mexico and
Canada did you hear that wants to get
rid of the NAFTA agreement with Mexico
and Canada yeah people are saying it's
the first time Trump has ever turned
down a three-way you didn't even use
color when you use that it's all in one
pen I'm obsessed with this I want to
make a sign put a niche literally
half-hardy yes it's a sticker and you
then you just it's behind a sticker okay
fine I'm gonna continue with this but
I'm sure I'm gonna let this drop
eventually yeah here's a crazy thing
you've probably heard about this there
is a story circulating that President
Trump has an illegitimate child yeah
yeah if this is true it's the first time
in history that an illegitimate child of
a billionaire does not want to meet its
father
when has that ever happened when in
France in France a beach closed because
a dolphin was trying to have sex with
swimmers here's the sad part the dolphin
was Dan Marino come on Dan come out a
report out of the UK claims a vet viagra
use has been linked to an early death
yes
yeah when reached for comment men in the
UK said still worth it he died and you
can't fall down
[Applause]
and boiling and your apologies signs
looking better all the time
a new study reveals THC THC appears in
breast milk for up to six days after the
mom has used marijuana yes yeah so
finally an explanation for why a lot of
babies just can't hold a job
[Applause]
you